aucune étude qui
prend le projet de tunnel quatre voies
dont deux voies pour le transport
collectif une à bout de patience
françois legault a lâché le morceau en
marge d'un point de presse vendredi
matin précise de dévoiler les études qui
appuient le projet de tunnel de la cac
le chef admet qu'elle n'existe pas les
études qui avaient été faites des études
qui avait été demandé par les libéraux
qui parlait pas de tunnel quatre voies
centre-ville à centre-ville et je suis
en faveur d'un troisième lien sous
philippe couillard en 2016 le parti
libéral avait effectivement envisager la
construction d'un tunnel entre québec et
lévis mais à l'ouest de l'île d'orléans
c'est la cas qu'en janvier 2020 qui a
choisi de recentrer le projet entre les
deux centre-ville près de trois ans plus
tard l'absence d'une étude pour appuyer
le changement de décision sème la
consternation à québec on pensait
qu'avec les études mais qui cache et
c'est payant non post le projet actuel
j'en reviens pas sont en train de dire
on va mettre 7 milliards sur une
question de feeling c'est pas
inacceptable et injustifiée c'est
scandaleux solidaires et libéraux tirent
à boulet rouge sur le gouvernement
sortant le candidat du plq crois que la
caq n'a rien fait pour diminuer la
congestion à québec en quatre ans et que
le projet de tunnel n'a été qu'une
diversion c'est l'image du bricolage
khakis d'un dossier du troisième mais
c'est claude lafortune n'aurait pas fait
mieux ils ont fait des maquettes qui
nous ait mis assez de nous impressionner
avec ça mais c'est toujours basé sur
rien le chef du parti conservateur éric
duhaime somme la caq de dévoiler
l'ensemble des données qu'elle détient
sur son tunnel françois legault demande
encore un peu de patience à la
population mais reste déterminé à livrer
le projet on espère dans prochaines
années à être capable d'avoir appelé
toutes les résultats des études puis on
continue d'avancer parce qu'on a besoin
d'un troisième mandat selon une
évaluation préliminaire le tunnel porté
par la coalition avenir québec pourrait
coûter 6 milliard et demi de dollars